ils ont tous les deux 23 ans ils sont
tous les deux ivelinois ils rêvent
d'aventure Tangi pichelot et Simon Bay
seront au départ du 4L Trophy 2024 les
deux anciens élèves du lycée blanche
dectille du chin et rencour ont décidé
de participer pour la première fois à
cette course d'orientation destinée au
18 28 ans alors le 4L Trophy on en a
entendu parler bah c'est un événement
qui était assez connu dans notre groupe
de potes et qu'on avait toujours eu un
peu envie de faire c'est juste qu'on
s'est dit qu'on le ferait plutôt quand
on commencerait à travailler plutôt
qu'étant étudiant parce qu'il y a
beaucoup de contraintes avec les examens
donc on a décidé de se lancer là-dedans
parce que je savais que j'allais
commencer à travailler bientôt et que
Simon aussi aurait fini ses études et et
aussi parce que on a cié que c'était le
moment parfait pour le faire depuis
février dernier Simon et Tangui mettent
tout en œuf pourquoi leur aventure roule
le duo a trouvé sa quat aelle dans le 93
début mai ils ont ensuite refait le
moteur la carrosserie l'embrayage du
véhicule ils vont maintenant apprendre à
maîtriser la voiture avant que la
compétition ne débute pas si simple pour
ces deux novic on apprend sur le tas on
regarde des tutos sur Youtube et on
apprend avec les mécaniciens qui nous
ont aidé à réparer la voiture euh donc
non ça nous fait pas trop peur parce que
en fait le le principe du 4 Trice c'est
aussi la solidarité donc c'està dire que
dès qu'on voit un équipage arrêté sur le
bord de la route bah le but c'est
d'aller les aider c'est pas vraiment une
course à proprement parler c'est une
course d'orientation et ce qui compte
c'est vraiment faire le moins de
kilomètr possible en fait sur la
totalité du trajet ce projet de 6500 km
au total est également humanitaire pour
le duo ils vont collecter en amont des
fournitures scolaires en parten avec
l'ancien lycée Blanche de Castille pour
les distribuer aux enfants le but en
fait c'est d'apporter des fournitures
scolaires aux enfants du désert du sud
marocain à merzuga et en fait bah tout
simplement c'est c'est ce pourquoi on
voulait le faire c'est c'est une visé
humanitaire aider les autres quelque
chose qui a du sens et qui est concret
surtout pour nous Paron va vraiment
distribuer des fures scolaires pour que
les enfants du désert travaillent dans
les meilleures conditions possibles
simplement les deux ivelinois prendront
la route au volant de leur quat le 12
février prochain direction biarit les
étapes de vérification
le grand départ élu programmé le 15
février au total il traverseront 3 pays
en 10
jours